やばいモンハンだよモンハン
いや、部位破壊してやりますよ
え？大丈夫ですか？
(プイ：興味ないわ)
(プイ：おいおいやめろって)
はははｗｗ
(プイ：だから興味ないんだよ)
あははｗちょっと待って待って待って
カメラマン：左の子は？
(いいのか？そんなに手出して？)
うわぁ！あっ！はっはっはっはっは！
iZoo園長さん）園長グッズね
はじめ）ははｗすげーｗ
園長）コースターとかメモ帳とか
はじめ）ははｗｗすげー
はじめ）やったーありがとうございます
はじめ）というわけで今日は
はじめ）昔、園長さんのカメの池を作るっていうやつで
はじめ）100万円ぶち込んで、させていただいたんですけど
はじめ）その池が今日は完成された
園長）そう、完成したんで
はじめ）はい
園長）最初に名前をつけもらって
はじめ）あ、そっか
園長）命名権があった　はじめしゃちょーに
はじめ）そうだそうだ
はじめ）100万円いれた人だけなんですよね？
園長）そう、100万円クラウドファンディングしていただいた1人だけ
園長）その人に命名権があるんです
はじめ）おっ池の名前を
園長）池の名前を
はじめ）っしゃあー！
はじめ）実際に池を見てみたいところではありますね
園長）うん
はじめ）わーすごい道も補正されてる
園長）ほら
はじめ）あれかーうわっすげー
はじめ）え、これなんか緑色いのってやばいですか？
園長）いやこれ苔
はじめ）あ！苔か
はじめ）僕入ったらなんか…
園長）入っていいよ(即答)
はじめ）本当ですか？
園長）うん
はじめ）これって何匹ぐらいカメ入るんでしたっけ？
園長）ここね入れれば8000匹ぐらいかな、最高で
はじめ）8000かぁ…
園長）いやー本当におかげさま
はじめ）いやいや
園長）ありがとう　カメも喜ぶしね
園長）うちも本当に助かりました
はじめ）あ、いえ
はじめ）YouTuberのSEIKINさんって方がいるんですけど
園長）うんうん
はじめ）その方も結構お金を
園長）そうそうそうそう
はじめ）｢応援しています｣とのことでした
園長）ありがとうございます
園長）2人がなん、なん、ワンツーを
はじめ）あ、はい
園長）本当に引き取り多いんだよね
はじめ）う〜ん
園長）本当に多いの　毎日のように今きてるから
はじめ）毎日来るんですか？
園長）毎日
はじめ）名前を考えてきたんですけど
園長）はい
はじめ）あのうちにですねー
はじめ）のぶ子っていうエイリアンがいまして
園長）はい
はじめ）ちょっとこの子をこの池に設置させていただければ嬉しいなと
園長）ここに？
はじめ）はい
はじめ）大丈夫ですか？
園長）大丈夫
はじめ）のぶ湖
園長）のぶ湖の"こ"は？
はじめ）エイリアンの方は子供なんですけど
園長）ふふｗうんｗ
はじめ）池はのぶ湖であのみずうみの方で　そうです
園長）のぶ湖だもんなｗｗ
はじめ）できればちょっと嬉しいなと
園長）了解(即答)
はじめ）思って…いいですか？
園長）もちろんもちろん
はじめ）やったー
園長）だって命名権ははじめしゃちょーじゃん
はじめ）あーまぁまぁまぁまぁそう、そうですね
園長）うん
はじめ）え、多分のぶ子どこに置けますかね？
園長）のぶ子どこに置いてもいいよ　大きいの？
はじめ）あっ今あそこに
園長）入るの？
はじめ）入ります！
園長）お〜
はじめ）じゃ入りまーす
はじめ）う"あ"あ"冷てー　あっでも気持ちー
(カンッ)
はじめ）うわっあっはっ
はじめ）あ〜〜〜〜(奇声)はっはっ
園長）おぉ〜おし、結構深い
たなっち）助けてってなんすか？ｗ
はじめ）上がれなくなっちゃった　助けて
たなっち）落ち着いてください一旦落ち着いてください
はじめ）よしよしまっ、たなっち助けて
たなっち）落ち着いてください
はじめ）あーわかった
たなっち）落ち着いて！落ちつ、落ち着いて本当に
はじめ）わかったわかったたなっち
たなっち）本当に落ち着いて本当に落ち着いて落ち着いて
はじめ）たなっち助けて　助けて
たなっち）待って待ってどういうこと？どういうこと？
はじめ）助けて　たなっち助けて
はじめ）助けてたなっち
たなっち）助けてって
はじめ）たなっち！
たなっち）ねぇ
はじめ）助けて〜
たなっち）ああぁぁあぁあぁぁああ
たなっち）出れなくなっちゃいました
だいち）出れない？
たなっち）助けて
はじめ）助けて　まじ助けて
はじめ）助けて　だいち君助けて
だいち）大丈夫？
はじめ）だいち君助けてー！
だいち）大丈夫か？大丈夫か？
はじめ）助けて
たなっち）だいち君助けて
だいち）本当に大丈夫か？
はじめ・たなっち）せーの
はじめ）園長さんｗｗｗ
たなっち・だいち）ｗｗｗｗｗ
はじめ）園長さん
園長）よいしょ
はじめ・たなっち・だいち）助けて　園長さん助けて
はじめ・たなっち・だいち）せーの
だいち）あはははｗｗｗ
はじめ）バカンスやで
はじめ）うん　いいと思います完成でーす
一同拍手
園長）これ　今から選んでもらう
はじめ）おっ
はじめ）23センチ
園長）はい、こちらで選んで
はじめ）あっ、名前が決めれるんですね
園長）名前が決められる
はじめ）うわっすげー
園長）そうこれスペシャルじゃんトゲトゲしてる子
園長）じゃこれ名前をつけていただいて
はじめ）はい
園長）1匹目を入れましょう
はじめ）あ、そうか入水の作業だ
うわ　うわ　うわ　うわー
誰かー　待って
落ち着けっちょおい、落ち着け
かわいいねぇ名前どうしよっかな〜
やっぱ顔見て判断したい顔見て判断したい
出たり入ったりしてるねー
ｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗ
【はじめしゃちょーエンディング】
ざぶぅーん
よいしょ
うぉおっ！
よしー
はい